all eyes on Nevada as Clark County
continues to tally votes the U.S Senate
Congress and Governor's races some of
the most watched in the nation eight
news now investigator Vanessa Murphy is
live in front of Clark County election
headquarters in North Las Vegas with the
latest Vanessa
well the question we keep on getting is
why does Nevada take so long to count
votes and specifically Clark County the
Registrar of Voters says his staff is
simply following the law and as we speak
election workers are in this building
right now tallying votes here's some
video we shot earlier just over an hour
ago the county advising us to not show
election workers or observers faces as
of last night all in-person votes were
counted but mail ballots postmarked by
November 8th and arriving by Saturday
will still have to be counted here's
what Clark County Registrar of Voters
Joe Gloria says he is in charge of this
operation
in Clark County we're a unique
jurisdiction we're still servicing a
full service in-person voting
opportunity for voters during early
voting and election day
in addition to that we're providing a
mail ballot to every single voter so
when we're focused on Election Day we
can't also focus on getting those
and what's the deadline Gloria says by
law Mill ballots have to be counted by
Tuesday also Clark County has until
November 18th that's next Thursday for
the Commissioners to certify the
election results here as of noon today
Gloria said nearly 28 thousand mail
ballots were at headquarters and
beginning to be processed they're also
working on signature curing that's for
mail ballots where they might not have
signatures or the signatures don't match
what's on record they are trying to
reach those voters I'll have more on
that coming up at six back to you
Vanessa these are all big tasks what
kind of hours are these workers putting
in there
a spokesman telling us they are
beginning their day at 6 a.m and
Counting until about 10 p.m we're also
expected to get uh updated election
results at least once a day we just
don't know what time yet we're working
to find that out back to you thank you
so much Vanessa